jarasch o'barry fragt was war dein
traumberuf als kind ich hatte keine
ahnung was ich machen wollte ist
verdient wirklich unfallart ich zur
schauspielerei gekommen und wollte
vorher nach kanada aus einem holz zu
hacken ich habe mich mal beworben viele
bohrinsel um schnell geld zu verdienen
und weltreisen 90ern ich hatte echt kein
plan und bin ich über einen kneipen job
irgendwie die schauspielerei
reingeschlittert toni jetzt möchte sich
engagieren haben wir auch gerade im talk
darüber gesprochen wie kann ich als
jugendliche schon im tierschutz tätig
werden beziehungsweise tiere retten und
nicht nur schnecken die das strahlt die
die straße entlang riechen
also so richtig anpacken gute frage es
gibt wenn du reisen kannst gibt es
großartige tier camps zwei schönen asien
indonesien thailand wo du tatsächlich
gerettet
ganz hoch päppeln kannst und ansonsten
konfiszierte tiere und bei uns finde ich
immer die guten angeles natürlich ist es
nach wie vor spannend dass tierschutz
betrifft es gibt jede menge tierheim als
wohn und ihr arbeiten kann
es gibt organisationen die einfach frank
wesemann es jetzt geld einsammeln zum
beispiel für orang utan schutz genießen
und wieder auffassung kleines beispiel
fans von nature
im netz die vier pfoten habt ihr
hauptsitz in österreich also es gibt
unzählige echt gute tiefes
organisationen da wirst du jetzt schnell
fündig mit 54 4 vorne frage was war
bisher seine schwierigste
schauspielrolle ich mal sagen wir
katharina die große das spiel ich den
ehemann von catherine zeta-jones da muss
ich ein infantilen alkoholiker spielen
sondern völlig degenerierten angst druck
geraten
der wahlweise im rausch war oder auch in
seinem roman ischen war das war so ein
durchgeknallter kopf und ich musste
geige spielen lernen für diese rolle das
war schwer aber hat am schluss ein
riesenspaß gemacht
lange ist mein partner möchte wissen ist
es überhaupt möglich die erde vor dem
raubbau des menschen zu schützen oder
steuern wir langsam aber sicher auf
einen kampf um ressourcen zu also ich
glaub der kampf um ressourcen ist längst
ausgebrochen beispiel was er beispiele
beispiel bodenschätze ich denke wenn wir
nicht wenn sich sowohl die politik als
auch die industrie als auch für kleine
endverbraucher echt unser verhalten
radikal ändern
steuern wir tatsächlich eine katastrophe
zu und das ist glaube ich auch dass sie
noch zu verhindern ist in der anderen
ein bisschen zusammenreißen blatt
gefragt wer sind deine schauspieler also
mein großes vorbild war im kino bei den
frauen immer kate winslet cate blanchett
bei den männern finde ich großartig sean
penn früher mal optimierung also noch so
richtig gespielt hat in deutschland war
immer ganz georgen großes vorbild armin
mueller-stahl franzosen hatten
großartige schauspieler ihrem auto die
alpen als porno mit brad pitt zeigt ab
denn hier hat dieser seite also ich
könnte jetzt wahrscheinlich eine halbe
stunde nahm weiter
es gibt echt viele vorbildung bei den
musikern david rott hannes als was wäre
es die heute tätig wenn du nicht in der
schauspielbranche als schauspieler oder
drehbuchautor tätig wärs denn ich glaube
ich war teilweise fotograf oder
journalist geworden oder in der idealen
kombi beides fotorealismus finde ich
einen ganz spannenden beruf und kriegst
auch also ich habe ein großes faible gab
für journalismus der da dorthin geht wo
sonst eigentlich niemand hingeht und
befragt handel siehst du dich als
deutschen george clooney
also das ist ein riesen kompliment ich
wünschte ich würde die tribüne auf dem
tisch bekommen die george clooney hat
und auch seine gagen verdienen weil mit
denen macht er echt tolle sachen über
alle wissen dass ich sie mich eher ein
vorbild aber mit den verglichen zu
werden tut mir mal gar nicht weg